démange a vu l'interview de sa mêlée
paul hadj qui font rêver de la mine
après impôts si vous rêvez pas ce que
lui même il arrive et d'amour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'année la vente je me rappelle guest en
2018 les 1018 je suis arrivé j'ai testé
bon on m'avait dit de l'année prochaine
les deux groupes étaient jusqu'à hier un
pur et non cela n'est que celui que je
veux participer encore comment
sélectionner
[Musique]
on rêve d'abord
défini ma formation avait un contrat
professionnel et
continue à l'écran j'ai travaillé écrit
aussi où on en est là l'histoire du
football et dans mon pays ait jamais eus
les notables joue aussi une coupe
d'afrique en coupe du monde elles sont
ici jamais d'aller à montpellier
et puis et c'est le travail
m'adapte au nord et à l'est dans les
autres pop était un peu du home as a
real madrid
nous avons deux anciens trois anciens
stagiaires de le mbc qui participe à la
can donc c'est pour nous c'est
valorisant c'est un vrai plaisir et
c'est des enfants qui conte a côtoyé ici
au centre est
et qui défendent aujourd'hui les
couleurs du cameroun et pour nous c'est
le but ultime avoirs des anciens
stagiaires qui défendent les couleurs du
pays c'est très très valorisant
triquet
j'étais fort mais c'est après bon j'ai
pas eu la chance d'être footballeur
professionnel je connais mes échecs je
connais les manquements et aujourd'hui
j'essaie de les amener à grandi et a
fait ces choses que nous on n'a pas pu
faire à notre époque on est est un homme
venait juste pendant les vacances fait
des petits cons aujourd'hui son
stagiaire ils sont à l'internât
complètement et fréquenté s'ils sont ni
son nouveau jeu logés et nourris dans le
cadre du suivi dont je le dis souvent
vous avez beaucoup de chance il faut
profiter pourquoi pas essayer de toucher
les rêves que vous avez quand vous
entrez ici
de damas
dans le bain de football c'est à peu
près tous les dix ans qu'une académie
comme la nôtre sont grands un grand
talent a donc naturellement on a eu des
passages à vide où on avait des talents
moyens mais depuis un moment on commence
à avoir grâce au travail qu'on fait
depuis cette dizaine d'années la des
talents de très haut niveau qui feront
parler d'eux dans les très prochaines
années cette année on a deux joueurs qui
vont aller respectivement à lille et à
marseille dans ce qui est quand même des
taux de transfert pour ce qui concerne
notre notre académie
et nous parle de la paroisse l'opinion
puisque c'est pas facile qu'il faut être
discipliné tout pour pouvoir
être sur la voie ça nous donne souvent
des frissons de les voir les voir passer
aussi on a les rêves qu'on avait aussi
des rêves comme quand les vois ça fait
beaucoup